hey folks welcome to the dark Horus
podcast live stream number 206 it's the
first one of the Year 2024 if I'm not
mistaken and I think I really can't be
please tell me 2020 24 that's a lot of
20s 2024 is not going to be cadenced the
way you were just talking wow what did I
say
you were just taking a lot of breaks in
your sentences almost like a stuttering
stammering kind of Captain Kirk maybe I
think we're going to have to behave very
carefully in 2024 just because of all
the Peril well here we are St of course
you are Brett Weinstein doctor Dr Brett
Weinstein I am Heather hying do and uh
here we are uh please join us on Rumble
and uh we're having a watch party on
locals you can join us there we're not
going to kind to do a Q&A today we're
going to reduce those to uh once a once
a month I think uh do the second episode
of the month so there'll be one next
week and we had um our private Q&A uh
which we which we've been doing since
gosh almost the beginning of our live
streams on the last Sunday of the month
this last weekend and they're always
great so join us at locals to get access
to those and um and what else mostly
we're going to be spending the time at
the end telling you about more ways to
find us and uh find merch and such but
we do start with our three sponsors at
the top of the hour every time and we
will be doing that as well right now all
right okay uh so we have as always three
sponsors uh they are carefully Chosen
and we really appreciate all of them our
first sponsor this week is Helix Helix
makes truly fantastic mattresses that
are supremely sleep enhancing have you
ever been traveling and climbed into bed
only to discover that the mattress was
not comfortable able conversely have you
ever experienced the feeling of relief
when you discover a great mattress one
that lets you sleep comfortably through
the night Helix is that mattress it is
amazing what a difference it makes Helix
sleep is a premium mattress brand that
offers 20 different mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences you can
take the Helix sleep quiz online in less
than 2 minutes you'll be directed to
which of their many mattresses is best
for you do you sleep on your back your
stomach or your side do you toss and
turn or sleep like a log do you prefer a
firmer or softer mattress all of these
are taken into consider consideration
with the Helix sleep quiz and they have
special mattresses for Big and Tall
adults and one for kids as well once you
found your perfect mattress which we did
it shipped straight to your door not
ours but yours uh free of charge then
you'll have a 100 nights to try it out
without any penalty penalty if you love
it which you almost certainly will
they've got 10 to 15 year ma warranties
on all of their mattresses every Helix
mattress combines individually wrapped
steel coils in the base with premium
foam layers on top providing excellent
support for your spine and comfort for
for all of you Helix has been awarded
the rank of number one mattress by both
GQ and Wired Magazine they are made in
America at their very own manufacturing
facility they're built for human bodies
and built to last Helix also supports
military First Responders teachers and
students by giving them a special
discount we've had our Helix mattress
for over a year now and look forward to
it providing us with gear of excellent
sleep it really is a great mattress
Helix is offering 20% of all mattress
orders and no Helix is offering 20% off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to helixsleep.com
Darkhorse and use code Helix
partner2 uh at checkout this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
once again that's Helix sleep HX
sleep.com
Darkhorse and use the code Helix
partner2 at checkout this is their best
offer it won't last long with Helix
better sleep starts now yeah they they
really are utterly
sfic
which is not usually what you want in a
product but in a mattress it is in a
mattress it's what you're sh for it is
it is what you're shooting for and you
don't want to be shooting for anything
in a mattress no no
I right yeah it's it's tough if we're
going to insist on using only uh
metaphors and adjectives that are
appropriate to the product actually we
should do a year of of uh no we
shouldn't speaking entirely
metaphorically no not this year you
could you go ahead and try maybe next
year I you know I think you know why
don't you why don't you it's okay you
can start late I'll I'll give you the
first two days for the first two days of
semi
literalism and then I go complet
completely metaphorical uh no I I
thought it was the
opposite no no I'm hoping to do a year
but I don't think it's going to be this
one Speaking entirely
metaphorically oh I did not understand
that that's what you were arguing for
now that that's actually um you're
closer than you think um it's remarkable
how much metaphor is in our language in
places that we we just do not understand
it to be it's the water we swim in but
that's the obvious
stuff you know why why are higher
temperatures
higher that's a
metaphor yep I guess you're right about
that yeah that's just that's just an
obvious one but there there it's
everywhere it's everywhere it's
everywhere yeah yeah okay our second
sponsor this week is ancient it's armor
armor is colossal
colostrum is the first food that every
mammal eats produced in the first two or
3 days of an infant's life and is
nutritionally different from the milk
that comes in afterwards mammals have
existed for 300 million years give or
take a few tens of millions of years and
the first food every mammal has eaten is
colostrum colostrum serves many vital
functions including that of protecting
and strengthening the mucosal barriers
of infants before their own barriers
mature modern living breaks down your
mucosal and immune barriers and Arma is
the superfood that builds it back Arma
colostrum protects and strengthens your
body's barri barriers creating a seal
that guards against inflammation and
everyday toxins pollutants and threats
armor uses their cold chain biop poent
technology to concentrate colostrums 400
plus living nutrients into their most
pure and bioavailable form according to
a review published in the journal
clinical nutrition open science in 2022
bovine colostrum has been used to treat
cancer AIDS polio heart disease and
rheumatoid arthritis it is a general
anti-inflammatory and its use in adults
is known to increase lean muscle mass
improve athletic performance and
recovery time support healthy digestion
and reduce allergy symptoms armor starts
with sustainably sourced colostrum from
grassfed cows from their Co-op of dairy
farms in the US and they Source only the
Surplus colostrum after calves are fully
fed unlike most colostrums which use
heat pasteurization that depletes
nutrient potency armor uses their cold
chain biop poent technology an
Innovative process that purifies and
preserves the Integrity of hundreds of
bioactive nutrients while removing
cassine and fat to guarantee the highest
potency and bioavailability of any
colostrum available on the market the
quality control is far above industry
standards including being certified to
be glyphosate
free benefits of armor colostrum also
include clearing of blemishes Shiner
Shiner Shiner thicker
hair shinier thicker hair a
stabilization of blood sugar levels and
acceleration of fat Bry it does not give
you shiners that's not one of the one of
the benefits at all shinier thicker hair
that was and colostrum has been shown to
significantly improve Fitness endurance
and significantly decrease recovery time
after intense exercise armor has a
special offer for the Darkhorse audience
receive 15% off your first order go to
tr armor.com Darkhorse or enter
Darkhorse to get 15% off your first
order that's TR r y a
rm.com
Darkhorse our Shiner and thier hair
Shiner Shiner and thicker hair our final
sponsor this week is amican Hartford
gold you're here listening so you
probably already know just how unstable
our institutions are becoming and how
incompetent are our so-called experts
interest rates are Skyhigh we are caught
between runaway inflation and recession
while being assured that it is all fine
the cost of food housing Medical Care
schools everything except Yachts I'm led
to believe is climbing our leaders
increasingly make no sense at all all of
this threatens businesses jobs and
retirement funds finding ways to secure
your nest egg and insulate your your
wealth is more important than ever and
adding precious metals to your assets is
a great way to stabilize your
Investments and protect yourself
financially American hardford Gold is a
precious metals dealer that can help you
do just that American Heartford gold
helps individuals and families protect
their wealth by diversifi diversifying
with precious medals they make it simple
and easy to protect your savings and
retirement accounts with physical that
is not metaphorical gold and silver with
one short phone call that's also not
metaphorical they can have physical goal
gold and silver delivered right to your
door not a metaphor or inside your IRA
and 401K what if you only have a
metaphorical door uh that only works in
certain climates I mean short term yes
but most places you're going to want an
actual physical door delivered to your
door
frame um back to America not not the
service that any of our sponsors offer
if you are a door company looking to
deliver Doors to Door frames Conta
consider yes reach out um American hard
for gold is the highest rated firm in
the country with an A+ rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients and if you call them
right now they will give you up to
$5,000 of free silver on your first
qualifying order contact them today by
visiting the link in the episode
description below or call
8668281166
82811109
n889
again 866 82811109
n88
[Music]
99 so here we are yes you wanted to
start off with some resolutions some
resolutions yes not everyone is this way
but for me I find that resolutions are
more likely to be effective if I have
shared them and therefore feel a certain
amount of pressure to live up to them
and I am quite the opposite quite the
opposite I'm not going to share mine I
have uh depending on how you count three
resolutions that I would like to share
is it is are we also in the ma the year
of new
math you'll see at the end of this why
it's not 100% clear that it's three
other than four I see okay um my first
resolu I think we need to start with the
basics my first resolution for 2024 is
to make it to 2025 which in a normal
year might seem like a low bar but 2024
being what it is I think it's a a fairly
reasonable place to
start
okay I mean good right I'm glad for it I
very much hope you succeed you're you're
I don't know that that
counts let's put it this way if it was
my only resolution I think it wouldn't
count but given that it's one of a more
substantial list it's just you know
where to start I see okay uh second
resolu solution perhaps more concrete
than the first is that this year I am
finally going to learn to spell
necessarily and
fascism you can't spell fascism
necessarily I kind of get them and I can
spell it but it's got a lot of C's and
S's and rs and L's in there and you
never know what's doubled what's tripled
what doesn't show up at all but fascism
I can spell fascism but not on the first
try in general still well you know the
funny thing is it comes up a lot more
fre quently these days and yet I still
struggle with it so anyway I will this
year nail it you want to make a jab at
it right now
not it's still early it's still January
yeah I know so I've got
time I mean I I guess and tia doesn't
help right with their like smash the
fash uh epithets and such which would
suggest that it's
fism fascism yeah I'm not sure actually
why I have such trouble with this one
given that it's kind of an important
concept and I've done a lot of thinking
and a certain amount of writing about
but somehow it eludes me um so
okay all right and my third one is
setting the bar somewhere I don't know
where but you are setting the bar you'll
admit that this one we can at least on
the dawning of 2025 assess whether I've
succeeded we could do a live fire
exercise we could just have me spell
these
things necessarily in fascism yes in
2025 at the beginning of of 2025 we can
see I guarantee you you're not going to
be the one who keeps track of this
that's also likely so no I'm not
accepting the homework of keeping track
of this on your behalf I'm sure someone
out there will uh will will remember all
right I'm also going to lose 200 lb from
what oh I'm sorry 200 British pounds is
what I mean I'm by betting on well I
don't
[Laughter]
know I just think it's been a losing
horse perhaps sure or allows you
business
something oh my god well okay whenever
you're
done I do actually have a segue now
because you did not tell me you going to
do this until literally two seconds
before we finally started and you were
going to start somewhere else and you
don't get to go there next at this point
we're going to go to what the Oregon
Health Authority thinks that we should
resolve to do this year but that was
three only three for sure so I want to
know how that might have four
necessarily and fascism I could succeed
with necessarily fail and fascism or
vice
versa
no I want to know what you're betting on
that you're going to lose 200 lbs on um
I don't know I just think that the fear
of you know the fear of losing on a bet
can cause you to be risk averse and that
I should just let the chips fall where
they may and by chips I me french
fries all right maybe I should resolve
better jokes in 2024
maybe okay um this came into my inbox
this week or actually it was December
28th I believe is when this came in this
is a screenshot um from the Oregon
Health Authority which I'm still I still
get emails from them resolved to get
vaccinated wow it is never too late to
give yourself the gift of vaccination or
think of it as a gift for those around
you or make it a New Year's
resolution vaccination is the best way
to protect against severe illness from
respiratory viruses on the rise across
Oregon now we do not live in Oregon
anymore but uh this is what the uh the
hapless citizens of Oregon are being
subjected to while some resolutions
require making healthy changes for the
rest of your life we're asking you to
resolve to make an appointment for a
vaccination said Dean sidlinger
MD that's what his name appears be um
Health officer and state epidemiologist
at OHA again that's the Oregon Health
Authority we're not asking you to change
your behavior for the year we're asking
you to change your risk of getting sick
yeah like increasing it possibly given
what they're talking about they're
talking about specifically um the the
newest covid-19 flu and RSV
vaccines according to a report and you
may not be able to see that but report
is hot length in the original um
according and I'm going that becomes
relevant here according to a report
published last week by the sener for
Disease Control and prevention so
remember when you C when I asked you
this morning first thing upon seeing you
when you when you got up I said could
the CDC get any worse I recall you I was
in the middle of looking through this
report sounded like a trick question
well my sense was I didn't think it was
possible but it seems like they're doing
it so um according to a report published
last week by the CDC on Fall 2023
respiratory virus vaccination coverage
through December 9th among eligible
oregonians 18 and older 25 % have
received the 2023 2024 covid-19 vaccine
8% have received flu shot and 3% have
received the RSV that's the respiratory
s sensial sensial virus
vaccine people the OA uh helpfully uh
concludes can get the vaccines by
contacting their Health Plan healthc
care provider County Public Health
clinic or a federally qualified Health
Center or by calling
211 they can also Okay so
wow yeah Incredible You Know by
comparison your resolutions look A+ see
yeah
absolutely uh can you spell
vaccine yes okay okay so you don't need
to add that to your list um but check
out these numbers so it's like if you
would put it back um the report says
they say the OHA the organ health
authority says the report published by
the CDC says that oregonians only 25%
have received their newest covid-19
vaccine 8% the flu shot and 3% um the
RSV vaccine and in a different part of
the same email they have like a you know
expand here to read more and they have
this the same thing basically that I'm
showing you here in expanded form but
the numbers are totally different like
in this report I'm like oh are there two
reports I clicked through like it's the
same report so the the Oregon Health
Authority is putting out like just as
far as I can tell how's ardly chosen
probably not random they probably didn't
go to the effort to make it random have
Hazard chosen numbers to plug into these
to these emails they're sending I don't
even know how that's supposed to inspire
you to do anything but I went and looked
at the report itself to see what the
actual numbers were and um first off the
report is a dumpster fire it is a
disaster uh so here it is the morbidity
immortality weekly report helpfully put
out by the CDC influenza updated
covid-19 and respiratory what's the
again scial sensial sensial sensial
virus also cannot spell but yeah at this
point I can spell it and not pronounce
it which is generally going to be the
way it is if I can do one and not the
other I I I you know a partnership is
obviously in order yes yes I can right
now spell necessarily and fascism so oh
hell yeah yeah all right but maybe I
should start mispronouncing
them fascism that's that's if I
pronounce it that way then maybe you can
spell it right anyway um coverage among
adults V vaccination coverage among
adults Us Fall 2023 check out this this
sentence from the abstract I actually
now know what it means but it took me a
long
time overall approximately 27% and 41%
of adults aged more than eight equal to
or more than 18 years and 53% of adults
age more than or equal to 60 years
reported that they definitely or
probably will be vaccinated or were
unsure whether they would be vaccinated
against influenza covid-19 and RSV
respectively what
so unfortunately I have like just in the
last hour have figured out what they
what they are on
about I'm going to just read it one more
time yeah yeah yeah try to yeah and I'm
just going to go with more than 18 and
more than 60 years to make it to to make
it seem a little bit more like English
but you'll see that I don't get really
that much closer uh reading the abstract
from the cdc's recent report overall
approximately 27% and 41% of adults age
I'm going to start over overall
approximately 27% and 41% of adults God
adults
adult slow down
adults overall approximately 27% and 41%
of adults aged 18 years or older and 53%
of adults aged 60 years or older
reported that they definitely or
probably will be vaccinated or we're
unsure whether they would be vaccinated
against influenza covid-19 and RSV
respectively so check it out we got
three numbers okay we got two age groups
we got um definitely will be vaccinated
probably will be vaccinated un sure
whether they'll be vaccinated so three
states of vaccination plans and three
diseases which of those go together I
think I know I think I know so they are
lumping rep and also this entire piece
of pseudo research is based on they
called a bunch of people are like did
you okay cool if you say you did you did
are you gonna if you say You're Gonna
you're gonna so it's entirely
self-reports they didn't check
vaccination records they didn't do
anything okay um but this um definitely
or probably will be vaccinated or we're
unsure whether they would be vaccinated
that's everything okay the 27% the 41%
the
53% they that those those percentages
all of the like kind of maybe might get
vaccinated not yet but I'm definitely
not definitely not going to that's all
of this okay so 27% of
adults 18 years or
older say that they might get vaccinated
against
influenza 41% of adults aged 18 years or
older say that they might definitely
kind of maybe unsure get vaccinated
against covid-19
and 53% of adults age 60 years or older
say they might kind of maybe not don't
know uh will get vaccinated against RSV
so wait admittedly it's a little small
there so I'm having trouble parsing it
but am I right that they'd fail to
resolve the question of whether the
adults over 60 are included in the
adults over 18 which would therefore
argue that the
adults between those two oh you're not
understanding well true that's clearly
on you because how could you possibly
misread a sentence as clear as this yeah
no it's um that 27% yes is uh adults
aged eight adults adults aged 18 years
or older with regard to their plans for
influenza vaccination
the 41% of adults age 18 years or older
is with regard to their plans for covid
vaccination and then I don't know why
they went with a totally different age
range for the RS plans for RSV
vaccination but it's 53% of adults um
age 60 years or older think that they
might but haven't yet okay gotten
vaccinated against RSV this is actually
highly relevant to what we will be
talking about later but I I I don't
think ever saw the sitcom Alf alien life
form oh was that what that stood I don't
think I ever did either that was an
acronym yeah oh I didn't know that I
would recognize the puppet but I don't
think I ever saw the show yeah but I do
remember an interview with one of the
writers of the show who reported that
the writer's room was some cocaine
fueled craziness and that they had a
category that they would
sometimes not have you know it was a
half an hour show I guess um and they
would not have
enough stuff so they had humor likee
substance that they would include in the
skit and the idea was if you gave
something that sort of took the form of
a joke well especially if you've got uh
laugh track right then the point is it's
as good as a joke right because it feels
to people who aren't paying very close
attention that they're in a room full of
people laughing at whatever was just
said therefore it must have been funny y
um but anyway that paragraph that that
sentence in the abstract yep strikes me
as science likee substance right yep
it's not clear what they are claiming
it's not it's I think fairly clear that
they did not intend to convey anything
what they intended to do was give the
impression to somebody who was skimming
this that they're you know there's
numbers yeah that it was Quant
Quantified there's numbers and there's
categories and they've named the
categories and they've given you some
numbers so you proceed in fact the very
next sentence is strong provider
recommendations for and offers of
vaccination could increase influenza
covid-19 and RSV vaccination coverage oh
could really on like on what basis
they're making that claim they could
have written that sentence equally
easily frankly before covid-19 vaccines
even existed right like it's it's a non
it's a non claim that sounds concrete
much as a category that unites people
who claim to have gotten the vaccine
with people who claim that they intend
to get the vaccine no no no this is this
this is not include those who have
gotten the
vaccine reported that they definitely or
probably will be vaccinated or unsure
whether they would be vaccinated against
influenza the only people excluded yeah
from these the 27% 41% and 53% of adults
except those younger than 18 for the
first two and younger than 16 for the
final one the only people excluded are
those who claim that they have gotten
vaccinated and again no checks or those
who claim that they are not going to
this is everyone else this is and again
um they they had like three they had
three options they had five options are
you did have you gotten this vaccine yet
um are you definitely not going to and
then the other three are I definitely
will I probably will I'm unsure if I
will and that's they lumped them what's
passing for yeah yeah it's obvious
viously not it you will grant that that
paper takes the form of a scientific
publication science like material it's
science like material y
exactly uh a little bit of scrutiny
reveals that it means nothing yep says
nothing is based on shaky data to begin
with yep and that data is lumped in a
way that it doesn't tell you anything
nothing um
but well I want to quantifi yeah it's
it's at least pseudo quantify I mean
something was counted well let's put it
so for people who don't know what pseudo
quantification is pseudo quantification
can take place in a form that is clear
right where you take something that is
not quantitative and you make it appear
quantitative um this is simultaneously
pseudo quantitative and
um utterly ambiguous yeah now the
creating five categories and um then
acting like they are
discreet uh and that they could be
assigned integer values uh where
integers are playing the part of numbers
and they're not actually y uh is is what
has been done here but um note too that
this is um you know this is about the
United States if I can have my if you
can show my screen again and I'm going
to go back and forth between a couple
things here this is United States and
this original um email that I showed you
theen screenshot from is about Oregon
and what the OHA the Oregon Health
Authority is claiming is that this very
report so brilliantly written and pseudo
Quan Quantified as it is uh claims that
this report shows that 25% of oregonians
18 and older um have received the covid
vaccine 8% have received a flu shot and
3% have received the RSV vaccine keep
those numbers in mind 28 25 8 and three
and then we're going to scroll down
where they split out
their crap data by by state okay uh and
they've got a bunch of you know graphs
um I'm going to come back to that one
okay so here's the state um by state
table
coverage um with influenza updated
covid-19 and respiratory sensial virus
vaccines among adults and that's again
18 and over so these are the same
numbers uh and again what the OA said
was for Oregon it was 258 and three I
believe going across and here we have uh
40% for uh influenza uh
25% for covid and 20% for
RSV wow so the numbers are just
completely off completely wrong I also I
don't know I was not able to figure out
in the amount of time that I spent
trying um what exactly how they at these
numbers but um cumulative unweighted
number would appear to be just the
sample size right right and then they've
got slightly different numbers um what
did
they as like I'm not it's it's not clear
they've got very similar numbers here
and so maybe that's just are very
similar right so maybe that's just the
numerator and they're not shown as the
nominator like I don't know but 3080 and
3078 if that's if that's just an
an I don't know what they've done so OHA
clearly
completely falsely portrayed what the
numbers were but in a strange Direction
because I would have thought that they
would have been interested in over
representing how many people were
vaccinated um but these numbers don't
look anything like what the OHA reports
and the whole thing is a mess the whole
uh which oh this yeah um oh so actually
um this is in a different order so
um uh here we have influenza Co RSV and
here we have covid influenza RSV so
their number for covid is
25 and that's actually the only correct
number there okay um but 40 and 20 are
not represented here you know the funny
thing is I wish I had said it but I was
going to question that 8% on the flu
because in what Universe are are these
people who are not paying attention
enough that they're still getting covid
boosters but they're skeptical of the
flu shot or like what the hell yeah I
mean the only thing I thought was maybe
um some as the flu shot comes out later
I mean I I no longer pay any attention
to that at all if people were really
quick to get their booster and then just
have to make another appointment to get
the flu shot I don't know um but part of
what this reveals is you can't trust any
of the stuff that's coming out of either
you know organ health authority
reporting on the CDC or the CDC and
there was just one more sentence I
wanted
to um show here I guess this is um
related to what I read from the abstract
approximately 41% of all adults this is
us-wide now and 53% of adults age 60 old
older were
unvaccinated uh and this is with regard
to um influenza uh were unvaccinated but
reported that they definitely or
probably plan to receive or are unsure
about receiving updated covid-19 and RSV
vaccines respectively suggesting they
are open to vaccination okay so no that
it's impossible to read that is actually
Co and RSV again uh
and why are they reporting it in this
way right if there's one thing a
scientific publication should free you
from it is any need to condense things
that makes them less clear a a scient
publication if it airs in a direction at
all should air in the direction of being
um Beyond clear yeah and in fact it it
has to be in order for the scientific
form to be met it has to be something
that somebody else can reproduce and
check and to the extent that you've
introduced ambiguity by jamming stuff
into a sentence that you could have said
in four sentences so at least you could
match up the percentages with the thing
that they are claimed to apply to well I
mean I think so we've seen this move
both in the abstract and here right
where they put um you know they put
these three categories of
responses uh you know they're asking
people are you vaccinated are you
not if you're not what are your
plans I don't know actually what they
asked but we end up with five categories
claim to be vaccinated uh claim not to
be vaccinated and won't get vaccinated
and this is for each of the three types
of vaccines um claim to be vaccinated
but claim that you plan to claim to be
unvaccinated but claim that you plan to
claim that you are unvaccinated but you
probably will and claim that you're
unvaccinated but you're
unsure those three
categories at the end mean wildly
different things and maybe it doesn't
matter precisely because these are
self-reports on a phone by the people
who picked up and uh and we don't know
if this is reliable at all but basically
the CDC and then the OHA is picking this
up um are using the numbers from that
big group in the middle to say all of
these people are convincible all of
these people are reachable by your with
your shots if you can just remind them
and make it easy and really push it on
them when they show up in your doctor's
office like that is basically what the
message is here people who say they're
going to get vaccinated okay they want
they aren't going to require much just
give them that little extra push make
sure you make it easy people who say
probably they're going to need a little
a little bit more effort people who say
they're unsure they're going to need a
lot more of your effort but all of these
people are convincible the only people
we're not trying to convince we say now
are the people who say they're
absolutely not going to get our damn
shots but everyone else is basically in
this category that is of greatest
utility to what is now passing for
public health so all right this raises
an important question one of the things
that was done to orchestrate the madness
around the the covid vaccines yeah was
that doctors were manipulated in many
different ways they were incentivized
financially they were induced to get the
shots early which caused them to have uh
cognitive dissonance over whatever
danger they had put themselves in so
those doctors who were prone to lie to
themselves would end up lying to their
patients Etc um and so to the extent
that whatever monster decided to do that
decided to um coers our Medical
professionals into coercing
us is still at work and it isn't in any
way important because this isn't a real
scientific exploration of something what
it really is as you point out is a
cryptic attempt to Jin up that machine
that induces people to get these things
on the basis of social pressure yes and
look at how many people are you know
queuing up right up getting ready so if
what you need is a number that suggests
we've got a lot of convincible people
and you get that number by calling them
up and asking have you gotten your covid
vaccine in a world where you've told
people that a covid vaccine is a moral
good you are doing this as a service to
your community among other things not
only is it important to protect your
health a lie but it is important to
protect your community another lie and
so and then you know go back to that New
Year's resolution thing resolve to get
vaccinated can you put that up the idea
that it is a New Year's resolution again
reinforces the concept that it is
somehow inherently good to be vaccinated
rather than you know uh resolve not to
get your covid vaccine this year because
they're dangerous right that would be a
more
viable uh claim than this but the idea
is this is such an obvious good that it
as a you know as a resolution uh you
know I'm going to run three miles a day
right I'm going to get my Cod vaccine
that the idea that they would put those
into the same category again suggests
this um self betterment um modality and
the point is they are getting the
evidence calling people up who they've
already told that this is a a uh an uh
unalloyed good right
um those people are then you know are
you going to admit that you didn't get
your covid vaccine right they're in that
situation because somebody who's
interested in covid vaccines has just
phoned them so they're many of them are
going to lie because it's socially
awkward to say no I think it's
actually I I I think some of those lies
will happen but I think it's even easier
to lie out of the category of yeah
actually I'm not going to do that um so
I'll bet the unsure category was kind of
high but I'll bet um people who are like
you I'm really not going to do that uh
jumped into like yeah I don't know and
some number of people who are like geez
I'm kind of leaning against but I'm not
sure when like no no I'm going to do it
I'm probably going to do it um because
you know the even the language in these
categories actually mimics human
psychology right now I'm I'm totally
going to do that now you know at this
point I certainly would not answer it
that way but there are a lot of people
out there who you know we we see this
the uptake of these things at this point
of these of these covid boosters is so
low we know that most people are not
doing it um but when called by someone
who says have you done it yet what are
the chances you're going to do it
because you know it's good for you and
like you know presumably the people
calling weren't allowed to add because
you know it's good for you in in the
actual questionnaire part but the entire
you know the water we're swimming in is
um this is what you do in order to be
good to yourself and be and and to be
good to the people around you and
actually it fits with the other thing
that we've said about um the psychology
of folks who are not getting their
boosters that one of the reasons that
you know we have a majority of the
public has either
never wanted to get these vaccines or
has switched sides but we don't see a
population that has widely acknowledged
the fact that those of us who said hey
this can't possibly be safe we're right
in the end how are they doing that well
one way they're doing it is that not
getting your they may have decided in
their mind yeah I'm not getting this one
right they have switched sides but if
the idea is well I haven't gotten it yet
right then the point is it leaves them
room to lie to themselves about whether
or not they have actually come to accept
what some of us were saying all along
and uh this exploits that very thing in
order to get a inflated number or the
convincible in order to manipulate
doctors into pressuring people who walk
into the office and of course all of
that is Upstream of the various hazards
that seem to be associated with a
massive and growing number of excess
deaths somehow the system is pressuring
instead of you know you might imagine
that a dishonest system would just stop
pushing these damn shots and uh you know
would pretend that it was over and it
had never tried to get you to take them
but instead they you know when do they
stop doubling down what exactly would
tell them that this thing wasn't worth
the
risk that's that's not the kind of
information they're taking in yeah so
this actually um we're kind of going in
the opposite direction from where I
thought we would we're going to save
your your big stuff one more one more
section I'm I'm going to read a little
bit from my Natural Selections piece
this week sure um which I called era of
the false narrative New Year same
timeline and I start with seals and I'm
not going to read about the seals and
I'm not going to read about the soup at
the end um I encourage you to go and
find that yourselves uh but I'm going to
read this little section
here drug us with a steady diet of
titilating and Bol content on those
compact drug delivery devices that we
carry around around with us all the time
in our pockets in our hands glazed eyes
staring down beside us as we
sleep drug us with substances that are
not food but which play food on TV
create cravings and convince us that
denying ourselves real and honest food
is good for our hearts and that eating
the Shelf stable stop from Labs well
that is too drug us with actual drugs
both legal and not assure us that once
the government has given its stamp of
approval for this molecule but not that
one then taking this molecule is a sign
of virtue a sure indication that you too
will have access to Heaven while taking
that one is a sign of a weak and
unguarded moral
Center how foolish we are to believe
their stories it has been the stories
all along that have been at the center
of their power to control
us so I talked about uh Little Island
near us and here two more paragraphs um
about that little island across the way
where the seals Sleep When the tide is
low enough for them to do so I had a
dream it's a low slung narrow Island on
which corant and gulls Roost and baly
Les fly out to hunt those other birds
young and on the far side of it the
water is so deep and runs so fast the
conditions can be so chaotic that I have
sometimes seen boats of considerable
size unable to make the passage turning
around after straining against the
current and going back from once they
came in my dream a wide low gray boat
with no markings on it at all and no
portoles moves silently into view
stopping in front of the island a vast
door opens in the island a Tambour door
sliding up to reveal a gaping portal of
rectangular Darkness the unmarked boat
Glides in then descends as if on an
elevator out of view the door closes on
the physically impossible portal and
life looks normal once
again those intimations that we get the
glimmers at the edges of Consciousness
the didn't I see something about that
and that's odd and how could that
possibly be given what else I thought
was true they are worth paying attention
to what is happening outside of our view
what is known that we are not being told
what are the actual risks that we face
which we have not yet understood
these things are worth attending to but
we cannot live that way all the time
chasing the glimmers and the intimations
we cannot be in such a state of
vigilance at every moment of Our
Lives that's where I wanted to stop
perfect
um you have any well the problem is I do
have a reaction that is it fits
perfectly with what I was hoping to
discuss and you know it opens exactly
the right question about it
so um yeah all right so let's I thought
it might switch gears briefly and then
we will return to that uh
description I wanted to talk a little
bit about the Claudine gay
plagiarism uh resignation story and I
haven't read for those who have been uh
blissfully unaware um claudian gay is
the now resigned president of Harvard
who resigned after and we're going to
come back to why this is interesting in
a second but she resigned after she
received scrutiny following her
testimony in Congress where she had been
asked
um whether or not a um I'm trying to
remember the exact phraseology but
whether or not
somebody proposing the genocide of Jews
would be in violation of Harvard's code
of conduct and she along with her two uh
compatriots from MIT and from Penn said
that it would depend on context MH now
you and I talked about that when it
happened and
um what we said was that although these
people are indeed full full of crap and
this does indeed reveal exactly the
moral defect that it appears
to the problem is not with their answer
their answer is correct that context
does matter you could imagine somebody
in an an exercise on a college campus
proposing that you know if somebody was
told to um you know inhabit the role of
a Nazi trying to convince the public of
this that or the other they could in a
formal sense be proposing the genocide
of Jews they could be doing it because
it was the assignment the assignment is
not inherently a wrong assignment it's
no inherently more wrong than asking
somebody to act like Hitler for the
purpose of making a movie so yes it does
depend on context the problem with what
Claudine gay said is that it is part of
a double standard and the reason that
she said that it would depend on context
in in this case was was that it was the
genocide of Jews under question and if
she had been asked about the genocide of
transgender people or blacks or some
other group that is perceived to be um
downtrodden she would have given a
different answer now we can't say that
for sure because it didn't happen but we
can say as people who have lived in the
academy and seen this stuff unfold yes
it would have been a different answer
this was somehow special because it was
the genocide of Jews that was uh under
question so we don't need speech
standards in order to protect from this
what we need is a uh blind application
of the principles of the University
across the board irrespective of who is
being
discussed anyway so all of that but then
following her saying of this very
controversial thing and following the
resignation of the president of Penn who
had said almost the same words um
Claudine Gay's
scholarship became the focus of
scrutiny and it was discovered that
there were many instances in which she
had engaged in what was claimed to be
plagiarism and I have one such example
um here Zach do you want to put up the
image the screenshot
of um so this is a case in which this is
from The New York Times yeah this is
from The New York Times and they are
pointing to an instance in which he
appears to have plagiarized so um
someone named Dr hosch child said Sandy
Janks shows me uh the importance of
getting the data right and following
where they may lead without fear or
favor adding later that Mr Janks drove
me much harder than I sometimes wanted
to be driven okay so that was the work
that is supposed to have been
plagiarized here uh Claudine gay says or
Claudine gay thanked her thesis advisor
Gary King Who quote reminded me of the
importance of getting the data right and
following where they lead without fear
or favor she also thanked her family Who
quote drove me harder than I sometimes
wanted to be driven end
quote
now I have a very different reaction to
this than I've read Elsewhere on the one
hand yep it appears she lifted some
stuff from somebody else's work
there's no idea here and in all of the
places that she lifted stuff I don't
find anything particularly meaty that
she has stolen it's not that she's taken
some great idea and claimed it as her
own what she's done I I'm I am
completely unfamiliar with her
scholarship in its entirety is there
meting Us in the scholarship oh no right
so then you know that that's that's less
of a kindness to say like well
yes plagiarism but not the meaty stuff
well if there's no meaty stuff at all
then you
know she's stealing other people's words
and she's not offering anything new at
all her own or anyone else's this is
this is exactly what I'm getting is that
this is phony work to begin with okay
The Cutting and pasting of exact
phraseology the acknowledgements no less
I mean that's that's amazing it's can't
come up with your own words to thank
your own family right wow it's
incredible because it's incredibly lazy
yeah right this is a person who is
supposed to have written shallow
effectively a book it is shallow it's
grotesque and it suggests that she never
thought anybody was going to look at
this document in any serious way now um
the so let us just acknowledge some
basic fact facts here one the academy
has a problem with intellectual property
this is something I take very seriously
because when you traffic in ideas the
fact that within the academic framework
there is no way to protect an idea is um
very troubling and the reason it's so
troubling is because you have a
landscape in which a really good idea is
a very it is the fuel that is supposed
to drive your career forward but the
protections that exist for something uh
for intellectual property in the outside
world are effectively non-existent
inside the academy so the two tools that
you would use to protect something in
the outside world uh are trademark as
three trademark copyright and patent
right what we have in the academy is the
honor
System at the same time we have a
dramatically hierarchical system in
which the highly prized um seats have a
tremendous amount of power to uh
arbitrate disagreements so the people at
the top have the ability to take stuff
from others and there's very little that
can happen to them well I mean I
think maybe this is just trivial but you
know so you identify trade Mark
copyright and Patent Trademark is like
images mostly logos patent is bigger
more complex ideas and copyright
generally is words right so and and I
believe it's Universal it certainly was
the University of Michigan where we got
our degrees that upon um your
dissertation having been submitted by
you and accepted by your committee um
the University of Michigan accepting it
into its into its system um puts it
under copyright like it is now it is
then copyrighted and I believe that um
being published in a journal then
copyrights your work
but the PE riew system of course lays be
your work to those people who are deemed
most able to critique it in ad Long in
advance of it ever being published if
you are so lucky as to get it published
right now can you show uh Claudine Gay's
dissertation
can you make that
bigger uh yeah okay good and now scroll
down Page by
Page this is 1997 stop right there all
right so the fact is she did copyright
this now that will have happened
automatically as a result of her
submitting the dissertation and it being
accepted but that is in some ways that
is what I mean again
because unless she graduated from
University of Michigan which I don't
know that she I think Umi is actually
it's it happens to be the place that
that collects all the dissertation so
they do the copyrighting right like
right but what this does mean is that
actually I mean look okay that very
sloppy cut and paste yeah stealing of
somebody else's phraseology in the
acknowledgments of her own dissertation
right this is somebody who's not taking
pride in their work this is somebody
who's sneaking one by the authorities
because she she can and then she does go
on to copyright it and the copywriting
of it well again I I know it's automatic
but my point is she knew that it was
going to be copyrighted yeah so my point
is when you steal somebody's
stuff right and then you copyright it
that's actually um in a technical sense
maybe the biggest violation here but the
important point
is it is no the fact that that one phony
academic has been driven from their
position mind you I think she got to
keep her $900,000 a year saw this salary
just to go back into the faculty and
keep on producing garbage right um the
point is amazing we ought not pretend
that we've discovered a phony because
that's not what happened what happened
is we have universities full of phonies
where the person who's actually doing
something meaningful is the exception
rather than the rule we have entire
disciplines of which claudian gay is a
member of One that are phony to begin
with and it should be no surprise at all
that if
you if you if you scrutinize the work
from these places you're going to find
all manner of laziness you're going to
find uh logical inconsistencies you're
going to find
pilfering you're going to find uh every
every crime in the book is going to be
found there because these aren't serious
people to begin with and in claudine's
Gay's
case I think you know it this is so
troubling right how much damage is done
to race relations by having people wield
their race as a get out of jail free
card so that they guard garbage
scholarship can land them in the
presidency of the most prestigious
College in the country right that is no
accident that she got there she's very
good at playing the game and being good
at playing the game doesn't mean she's
not lazy it doesn't mean that it isn't
obvious it means that this was Harvard
was not uh did not think it was hiring a
great scholar to be their president it
was not depending on that president to
do anything important for them right it
was at best trying to effectively uh
improve its ESG score or whatever the
academic equivalent of that might be and
this is recently apparently she was the
shortest uh she had the shortest tenure
of any Harvard president six months six
months and a couple days yeah so it's
not like uh this is this happened before
George Floyd or even right in the
aftermath when a bunch of people were
screeing and and trying to look virtuous
for um the people who were throwing
Fireball s in the streets um but you
know she she had just ascended to the
presidency mid 2023 apparently and you
know I think if she had not had The
Misfortune of Being hauled in front of
Congress and questioned by uh a member
of a party that is hostile to the
academy um her obvious plagiarism in the
most you I mean you know how hard was it
for me to find her dissertation it took
me two minutes right so her dissertation
has been sit you know the president of
Harvard had a dissertation um you know
sitting in plain view and nobody gave a
damn because nobody serious thought that
her position in the world had anything
to do with her scholarship no Unlike
scientific uh unlike peer-reviewed
papers that are often paywalled because
the journals claim they need to make a
bck I think that all the sitations are
available at least all the ones that
have gone through the Umi system you
know which is where the Repository
dations exists in
America so I wanted to just point to a
couple things that I think we are
missing
one you know a hell of a lot more about
this than I do but College presidents
have a certain amount of
power Harvard hired a fraud for that
position but nobody is deeply troubled
by the fact that somebody was in charge
of something important important like
our Premier academic institution um who
isn't qualified to teach there much less
to lead the place um why not and yeah
they're not just
figureheads and and and they're not just
collecting funds well let's put it this
way
the I think there is a parallel here and
you know I think Joe Biden is just a
figurehead at this point he was a crony
uh capitalist politician was an
influence Peddler and now he's mentally
incompetent and we see the same lack of
disturbance among the people who should
be saying Hey Joe maybe it's time for
you to step down because you really you
know you've aged out of the ability to
even do the job yeah right the fact that
the the blue team is not doing that and
in fact are going to run him again
apparently um is evidence of the same
comfort that whoever the power players
are behind the scenes they know full
well that they aren't hiring Joe Biden
to make decisions over whether or not to
attack this or that country or how to
fix the economy or anything like that
he's got a totally different job and
it's to eat ice cream and look you know
like a grandpa um and you know to
plausibly explain why you know tens of
millions of Americans have you know
gotten out of bed to go vote for him
right that you know his job is to do
something and it isn't presidential
something else is doing the presidential
thing and we don't know what it is which
means we've got a massive constitutional
crisis likewise you know one of the
Premier scholars in the country turns
out to be a total fraud and the evidence
has been waiting for somebody to look
for it and the only reason they thought
to look for it was that um somebody
questioned her in an uncomfortable way
and she so
well I don't think you've already said
that she wasn't a premier scholar no one
took her to be a premier scholar one of
the Premier academics in the country who
we might imagine would only attain that
position by being a premier scholar was
clearly not and in fact was a fraud
right but it should be true there should
be lots of people who want the job of
president of Harvard yeah and we should
be able to have a system in which well
if lots of people want the job then at
the very least whoever is in that seat
ought to be a premier scholar so we've
got somebody sitting in a chair that
ought to have Premier scholar as one of
its requisites who isn't even that and
um
the where I wanted to go is that the the
collapse of the system in which the
people who are supposed to have the
skills don't have them nor do they
apparently need them is I think a
reflection of something quite a bit
deeper right we have newspapers that
don't report the news right they can be
sometimes embarrassed in into having to
report the news late after the news has
already become well known and so it
would be conspicuous that it didn't show
up in the paper but we have newspapers
that don't report the news why is that
well it is at the very least profitable
for insiders who have high quality
information to make sure everybody else
has low quality information so low qu
you know things that take the place of
newspapers you can go buy a newspaper
but it doesn't have the news in it right
that's good for keeping your
asymmetrical advantage that comes from
having information likewise universities
you can't very well have academics whose
obligation is to figure out the truth
empowered to go search for it wherever
as uh claudian gay did not say uh or at
least cut and paste rather than said
herself you know follow the data where
they may lead right I mean that's such a
nonsense thing for this person to have
said what is what do she even mean by
that right she means nothing it just
sounds good but the fact is academics
who who
not only collect data that might say
something interesting and then do follow
it where it leads right that's not
what's going on in Academia at all we
have we have agreed upon conclusions you
know covid vaccines are safe and
effective um global climate change is
the greatest threat that Humanity faces
and um we have to get our carbon
footprint under control by 2050 or blah
blah blah blah blah these things are
conclusions that we now have this pseudo
scholarship supporting and it shouldn't
be surprising that institutions that are
heavily invested in that have frauds at
their head this is all what it would
look like if somebody decided you know
what we can't very well have uh open
exploration for the truth what we have
to have is the in you know if we don't
have any institutions that seek the
truth then somebody will create them
what we have to have is something that
takes that Niche space and pretends to
still be interested in the truth but
isn't and that means we've got some uh
some plums to hand out like the
presidency you could give that to a
phony who would make you look like you
were um concerned about uh the
underrepresentation of certain races in
Academia but in fact it's the opposite
how insulting is it to the very
high-powered black academics that one of
the few recognizable academic faces
whose black turns out to be a total
phony right that she's now been driven
from this office in disgrace for
everyone it's it's terrible it's
absolutely
counterproductive um so anyway
uh which can you so it's funny how
promoting people uh by prioritizing
their IM mutable characteristics turns
out to be a bad
idea right and it
is let's put it this way you have um you
have Peter Bean Helen pluckrose and
James Lindsay having tried to make this
point in The Honorable Academic Way
right they actually ran a kind of a test
y um and uh demonstrated that the system
was fraudulent and you know yes it got
discussed but it didn't cause some major
upheaval in um the academy and you know
I will point out that the problem here
here is that there's all of this crowing
uh in the predicted places because
they've brought down Claudine gay with
scrutiny that revealed her plagiarism
but to imagine that CL gay is not a
significant part of this problem right
right she she won some kind of a contest
maybe she was particularly gifted in uh
using her immutable characteristics to
get where she was going and she knew how
to do it without without investing too
much in rephrasing other people's
scholarship right um but the point is no
to imagine you've solved anything if you
haven't noticed that it was a system
that was tailor made to give you this
kind of fraud in a position of power
then you've missed the point so really
the question is when are we going to
notice that those in those institutions
themselves these fields aren't real they
are not doing anything useful and you
know as I said to to Peter and Helen and
James when they revealed their project
to us the problem with their work
excellent as it was is that they didn't
run the same test on the supposedly uh
hard Sciences they didn't pressure test
the fields that we think are above this
crap and much tougher you have to
fabricate grants and such but um but yes
but it it was a limitation
uh that uh I think was impossible to get
around yeah I mean I'm not saying that
there there was any opportunity to do it
but I mean especially you know that was
all preco right right we have now seen
the premier journals we've seen all the
medical schools we've seen every
University Embrace not only
nonsense but dangerous nonsense nonsense
that maed people MH and it's there's
still isn't a you know major academic
campaign to figure out what the truth of
those vaccines actually was or what the
truth of the repurposed drugs actually
was there are still institutions of high
at in this country that have vaccine
mandates for their student body right so
I mean so almost every metric that you
can think of to see how confused the
academy remains like insistently so um
passes the test of yep insistently
confused and and not seeing the truth
not seeing the truth and the fact you
know what you would expect if this was
an organic failure of some kind what you
would expect is as people wake up you
would expect those institutions to you
know fine maybe they're super tankers
and they turn slowly but you would
expect them to turn 180° and the fact
that they don't means somebody's not
surprised by the reality turned out to
be true of the various treatments and
and of the disease itself right right it
didn't matter that the reality was the
opposite of what we were told because
you know the Insiders apparently didn't
believe that to begin with um but
when you look at the
Academy and you find that everywhere
that you I guess here's the
point I I don't know how to make it
exactly there's nothing about what
caused claudian gay to be scrutinized
and what was ultimately found that drove
her from Power those things are
unrelated we just became aware that this
person was in the presidency of Harvard
because she was questioned in a way that
we saw it and then her scholarship was
scrutinized and plagiarism was found she
was not the questioning had nothing to
do with plagiarism or anything else so
the point is right she didn't your point
is she did not fall from grace because
she turned out to be a bad
scholar she fell from
Grace let let me let me describe it this
way like what what is the pithy version
of why then here's the why okay
okay she was
powerful and then her embarrassment in
front of Congress her public
embarrassment made it possible to
scrutinize her work and have plagiarism
be meaningful enough to remove her from
the office right so the point is is she
was vulnerable because of the particular
topic on which she was humiliated and
that meant that this whole other topic
of whether she was a fraud became viable
right the dissimilarity between the two
things is really the key story here now
once and I guess and this this then
makes some sense of some number of
Talking Heads online are
enraged that she should go down for
plagiarism and that you know Chris rufo
should have some part in this and how
dare he right and the the person who
stole other people's work and put
together nothing of import or or
innovation and got a degree for it
that's the person you should be angry at
here um but maybe in part people aren't
because everyone was going along with it
no one thought to look the the the
charade is what we are all depending on
well here's here's the troubling
troubling interpretation is when you
decide that the university can't be
replaced by something else that what it
has to do is continue to inhabit that
Niche space so that nobody else you know
just as
Wikipedia continues to be the world's
Premiere encyclopedia even though it is
nakedly
political um the point is if there were
no Wikipedia somebody would invent it
right we know that we need one the fact
that Wikipedia still exist means you you
don't get a Wikipedia you have to take
that one and you have to deal with its
political bent if there were no
universities they'd be springing up all
over the place because they're really
important the fact that they still exist
means that they don't spring up it's
very hard to start when you have to
confront the question of of uh
accreditation and all of that and so you
have a system that has to continue to
exist so nobody replaces it that system
then becomes a jobs program for people
who have nothing real to contribute yeah
and the point is it's full of such
people you have lots and lots of people
who are learning to go through the
motions of the exercise of Truth seeking
in order to
gain uh a job to gain something that
makes you interesting at cocktail
parties they to gain a position in
society without actually doing anything
right but other than the part about the
cocktail party you also just described
college and high school and middle
school and elementary school right all
all formal education from kindergarten
up to the highest reaches you can
go have largely become these charades in
which I'm going to stand up here and
inform you of some things and maybe
they're true and maybe they're not and
maybe I care about you and maybe I don't
but as long as you just tell me back to
me what I said to you last week when I
give you a piece of paper that say says
is a test on it then we can all agree
that everything is fine and I'll give
you a pass or I'll give you a diploma or
I'll give you a lot of recommendation or
whatever it is and you can then go and
jump through the next hoop that we have
all collectively decided is worth
jumping through it is utterly
meaningless and it's a betrayal of the
the the truth of humanity which is that
there are things new Under the Sun and
we are capable of being Innovative and
creative and being exploratory and we're
all better than this like pretty much
all of us actually have the capacity to
be better than this and we have had our
education system just ripped to shreds
While most of us weren't even aware it
was happening yeah it's an insult to our
Humanity it really is and it goes back
to your dream at the end of the piece
that you wrote right so you said what is
it that is happening that's just out of
our view that we're unaware of you know
the island goes back to looking like an
island
um and which brings me to the the last
point which is going to sound like a
stretch for a moment but um New Year's
Eve we had
a an
X5 solar storm a solar flare flung off
the sun Um Zack do you want to show uh
that
picture from the Forbes article oh
um
so you can check this out but this was
the largest solar flare
[Music]
um for the last 6 years since 20
um
and you
know actually scroll back up to the
uh to the title yeah 2023 ends with the
strongest x-class solar flare for 6
years get ready for the Aurora right get
ready for the Aurora oh maybe we get get
a light show out of this well it turned
out I don't think we did but um here's
the problem with
this these solar
storms carry the potential to do
devastating damage down here on Earth I
think we talked in one of our last two
streams about uh the Carrington event
about the fact that Civilization has
become highly electric and electronic in
the intervening years since 185 59 uh
when the Carrington event happened and
that means that we have
vulnerabilities here's the point that
solar storm largest one I think what
largest one in the last six years means
is the largest one basing such that we
can see it I'm not I don't think we have
detectors on the far side of the sun um
looking at solar flares that happen out
of our view okay I don't know that but I
don't think so certainly we have a lot
better information on the side of the
Sun that we can see um the largest not
we're not just a just an astronomical
question we're not effectively tily
locked to I mean so that's not right
we're rotating but so is the sun we're
right yes the sun has so we are seeing a
different uh a different part of the sun
over time what different part even means
because it is effectively a
fluid right it's not a solid surface
it's not a solid but there is motion of
what is on the surface it moves in a
predictable Direction and stuff that
happens on our side of the sun wherever
we happen to be um is now highly
monitored right we see sunspots we see
solar storms um we see all of these
things
now this solar storm was not a big deal
even though it was an X5 CL solar STM
what made it not a big deal oh the fact
that it happened on the edge of the Sun
that was just coming towards the earth
right this got flung off mostly in a
direction that didn't hit the Earth
right so glancing
below now here's why I want to bring
this back to Claudine gay and Joe Biden
and the hollowing out of the system and
what happens outside of our
view you can bet that the next big solar
storm is not going to be a big deal and
you'll almost certainly be right because
it almost certainly won't be directed
right at us right the sun is immense and
if you draw we are far from it if you
draw lines away from the Sun almost
nothing hits us right so you can bet
almost every time it's going to be no
big deal even if it is a
huge huge solar storm that in principle
is cap capable of inducing a carington
event or Worse um that it will not be
directed at us but you could also if you
were smarter than that right instead of
just betting hey the next solar storm no
big deal don't worry about it you'll be
right right but if you bet sooner or
later one will be directed at us and it
will be big enough to cause completely
predictable problems and the time to
discuss that is actually right now right
here's a question for you that we need
to be discussing
if you put your emergency managers in a
position where if they turn off the grid
right if you turn off the
grid you're going to kill some people
there's some people dependent on the
grid you're going to create some Havoc
right with I don't know traffic signals
whatever it is there's going to be some
some loss there'll also be a huge amount
of inconvenience and most of the time if
you turn off the grid if you unhook the
Transformers so that they are less
vulnerable to these things things most
of the time you will have done it and
not gotten any benefit because the storm
wouldn't have induced these things but
if you don't do it when we do get a
direct hit
then you're creating a vulnerability
that is a severe challenge to Humanity's
ability to continue to function so if
you wanted to solve that problem you
would do a few things you would a figure
out how to immunize your managers who
decide whether or not to unplug these
things from looking stupid if they
unplug them needlessly right right it's
no dumber than putting on your seat Bel
even though you're pretty sure you're
not going to crash right you need to
have the seat Bel on when you do crash
and so you're not being a dummy putting
it on even though you know you go your
whole life putting on seat bels and
never have it pay you back um it doesn't
make you dumb yeah if you knew exactly
when you were a crash you probably
wouldn't have gotten in the car that
time right so the point is you put on
the C belt do we want the people who are
protecting us from the bizarrely rickety
system that we've established for
ourselves do we want them to have the
confidence that when they actually are
concerned about something that they make
the correct call so that we don't take
out a third of the North American grid
and can't bring it back up for a year
right do we want them empowered to
protect us or not do we want somebody
empowered to spend the money to build
the protective circuits into the
Transformers themselves so that the G is
itself not so vulnerable of course we do
but back to claudian gay instead of
having somebody who's actually capable
of looking at the evidence and
concluding what many of us who have
looked at the evidence on this topic
have have
understood right that we have a major
vulnerability we could be a lot safer we
can't be perfectly safe but we can be a
lot safer than we are and yet decade
after decade we don't make ourselves
safer because in general we don't get
hit right it's coming it's definitely
coming something like a one in8 chance
every decade of a major grid destroying
storm right we are gambling on that
every decade and you know we could start
work on it tomorrow and it could happen
to us you know in 2026 and we could only
be a small way through the project but
delay there's no sense in that so what
I'm getting is you can hollow out the
system you know what you can fire the
conductor of the orchestra on the night
of the big uh presentation and somebody
else can probably get up there and wave
the stick who didn't you know
participate with the orchestra and it'll
be good enough but you you're going to
need the conductor for the orchestra
you're going to need people who seek
truth even when that truth is awful and
hard to accept right you're going to
need new newspapers that um expose
corruption and confront us with the
failure of our Elites and that enrage
the public you need to have those things
and if you unhook them because you're
enjoying an economic advantage or a
political advantage that comes from the
public being in the dark if you aren't
troubled by the miseducation of other
people's children because frankly when
the public is stupid you have an easier
time controlling them right if that's
the game you're playing you are put
putting us all in incredible danger and
Claud Dean gay didn't cause this she
isn't important but she is a symptom of
the same malady and we keep running into
evidence of
it over and over and over again
yep I'm not sure what to say
um you you said that um
you intimated that high Ed is no longer
functional one possibility is that uh
people had an interest in other people's
children not being
educated that's a
possibility I think you said another you
had another possibility as well I guess
I'm I'm again coming back to
why like you know
if if there is something that it's very
important that most of us not
see that could
explain a lot of the behavior that we're
seeing the unhooking of competence and a
functionality across systems and people
and
institutions if not that
simple greed doesn't seem like it gets
you far enough I mean maybe I'm under
appreciating the role of greed in
people's motivating structure but really
the thing that I keep on coming back to
is what what don't they want us to
see I think that's a good question I
think there are things they don't want
us to see and I think covid was a very
good trial run yeah it it revealed their
capacity and there are a lot of things
hidden in plain sight and some of them
seemed so hamfisted like so you wanted
some of us to discover this and then to
watch as you know the the the people who
hadn't yet discovered it attacked the
people who had right like you it was it
was so useful at a at a mass formation
level and a now we know at least for 1.0
what camps people are in and we can
start separating people out into you
know new roles as 2.0 rolles in 2.0
rolls in well so let's say part of it is
there's
some stuff up that they don't want us to
know about and I do think one
possibility
is forget wealth for the moment yeah um
wealth is really a means to an end and
the end is power and
that you should expect that people who
have disproportionate power many of them
will dream of
having a
lock a way never to be dislodged from
their Superior position they imagine
stasis when nothing has been static so
far right but if you look at all the
stuff that is
being uh Advanced right Central Bank
digital currencies travel
restrictions a lot of these things if
you start not from the you know are you
imagining it or you're not imagining it
but if you start from well what if you
did have a bunch of Elites
who wanted to make sure that nothing
inconvenient like
uh democracy or scholarship could
dislodge them from their uh their
privileged position MH um what would
what would you need what's the minimum
set of tools you would need to make sure
that that can't happen anymore right
well you would come up with stuff like
this right you're going to need
emergencies to justify uh the
restrictions that will be placed on
people you're going to need to make sure
that they can't just tune you out and
spend their money as they will blah blah
blah blah blah so you know I don't know
that that is what's happening but I
certainly know it's irresponsible not to
wonder um but uh the other thing though
again it's it's an it's an analog to the
the thing that I I have said about
Goliath that Goliath is a hybrid between
outright conspiracies and emergent
properties always this is another one of
these you've got people who clearly will
conspire to make sure that their power
is as permanent as they can make it
right people who think in those terms
you also have a lot of people
who have gotten used to the fact that
when they cheat they get ahead and
nothing terrible happens right claudian
gay is a trivial example of this but
what that means is if you have let's say
that you were in a corporation and the
corporation had inconvenient people who
sought to figure out what was in the
corporation's interest and so your you
know backstabbing people was in danger
of being discovered because it was
counterproductive to the corporation's
interest well maybe you would act to get
rid of people who were really looking
out for the corporation because they
would threaten to expose you the
corporation doesn't collapse maybe
eventually it does maybe 50 years later
it does but nothing bad happens so if
you get a class of people who are in a
position of superior power because they
have
ignored the possibility of creating a
catastrophe you would get an emergent
Advance towards a very dangerous state
right in other words you could imagine a
lot of people locally blinding that
which might expose them causing a global
blindness that would expose you to all
kinds of dangers very real ones like uh
x-class solar storms right why are we
ignoring this well maybe because the the
the halls of Power are inhabited by
people who don't worry about those sorts
of things because if they had been the
sorts of people who had worried about
them they wouldn't have been able to
ruthlessly pursue power the way they've
done it you should expect the people at
the top to ignore everything that
doesn't Advance their interest and yes
you occasionally get exceptions to this
but most of the people there are there
because they're very good at the game
and the game involves not thinking about
the long- term it means thinking about
only that which materially comes out to
benefit you and that would explain why
we are ignoring things that can't
possibly be in anybody's interest right
it's in nobody's interest to have
civilization exposed to uh to solar
storm disruption I I really can't think
of you
know who would engineer that it's a
vulnerability that's so frightening and
threatens to disrupt anything you're
trying to build down here on Earth yeah
that we should be you know if there's
one thing that should unite us it's this
let's prevent the Sun from wiping us out
but it seems like an
abstraction and and you can't point to a
moment when it will
happen and and uh both of those things
make it harder for the human brain to
comprehend or to or to continue to
consider yes and you know at a game
theoretic level you should simply expect
those people who ignore those dangers to
outcompete those people who notice them
right if you are spending effort trying
to protect the Earth from solar flares
that is you did not spend advancing your
own cause yeah and what we need are you
know a sober Congress led by a
courageous president backed by an
independent
Judiciary to do what is necessary to
hedge out this which we can now
scientifically establish is a major
threat to
civilization um and we don't get it
because we have the corruptors have
enlarged the corruption
loophole because they are getting headed
in the short term at risk that they are
placing us all in in the long
term fantastic yeah Happy New Year to
you as well resolve to get vaccinated
Brett all right solve all of your
problems
yeah uh yeah I just I don't know what
else to say I think you know we'll keep
coming back to things related here but
um
it's going to be it's going to be an
interesting year well here's the thing
you know I'm always asked to uh you know
well what's the bright side and the fact
is there is a real one but it's always
going to be some version of the same
thing which is you know the Adaptive
Valley is a dark place and if you're
going to get to the higher Peak you're
going to go through that dark place and
there's no guarantee that you make it
but the fact that it's dark is not
inherently in and of itself bad because
we were going to have to go through
something and maybe we are finally
getting to the point where people are
awake enough to
act all
right I think we're there then we are we
are
there um we'll be back next week at the
same time same place and the following
week will actually be coming due on
Saturday uh in order to allow for some
some of us to go some places um but one
week from today we'll be back and we'll
do a Q&A then as well uh starting with a
question from our fabulous Discord
server so if you want to join Discord um
check us out on locals lots of stuff
going on in locals there been the watch
party while we've been doing this uh
we we published the guest episodes of of
Darkhorse a day early uh at locals we um
do occasional amas you did another one
last week or so something maybe not uh I
did one recently but I can't remember it
was in the past sometime that's
certainly true yeah um so do check us
out there and we've got of course the
store Darkhorse store.org uh sop until
proven otherwise feels kind
of kind of relevant at the moment a
little bit kind kind of relevant um but
also one of my new favorites blueberries
because oxident
happen you know it grew on me you you
first proposed that like 15 years ago
probably okay man good find yourself a
t-shirt company and go ahead and uh
yeah time founded yourself a podcast and
then uh we be able to create a t-shirt
so very good very very good get one of
your very own get one of your very own
exactly um we we also had our private
Q&A um associated with locals this last
Sunday of the month uh which we have a
lot of fun with um check me out at
natural selections. substack do.com
where I write uh every week most weeks
um you this weekend are going to have
your conversations from your patreon uh
this weekend I believe this weekend yes
first first weekend yes first Saturday
and Sunday of the month um so uh
reminder about our wonderful sponsors
this week they were Helix armur and
American Harford gold uh links will be
in the show notes and one last reminder
we are supported by you we are grateful
to you our audience uh we love hearing
from you uh we've been getting some um
some great cards and such lately
associated with the holiday season to
the um PO box that we have posted at
both of our uh websites um but we also
appreciate when you uh subscribe to the
rumble channel uh share our episodes
share the clips that you're finding on
Twitter um like things and uh and just
spread the word we appreciate it very
much so until we see you next time be
good to the ones you love eat good food
and get outside happy New Year
everyone
[Music]